in the summer of 1976 a mysterious
epidemic suddenly struck two central
african towns killing the majority of
its victims medical researchers
suspected the deadly Marburg virus to be
the culprit but what they saw in
microscope images was an entirely new
pathogen which would be named after the
nearby Ebola River like yellow fever or
dengue the disease caused by the Ebola
virus is a severe type of hemorrhagic
fever it begins by attacking the immune
system cells and neutralizing its
responses allowing the virus to
proliferate starting anywhere from 2 to
20 days after contraction initial
symptoms like high temperature aching
and sore throat resemble those of a
typical flu but quickly escalate to
vomiting rashes and diarrhea and as the
virus spreads it invades the lymph nodes
and vital organs such as kidneys and
liver causing them to lose function but
the virus itself is not what kills Ebola
victims instead the mounting cell deaths
trigger an immune system overload known
as a cytokine storm an explosion of
immune responses that damages blood
vessels causing both internal and
external bleeding the excessive fluid
loss and resulting complications can be
fatal within six to sixteen days of the
first symptoms though proper care and
rehydration therapy can significantly
reduce mortality rates in patients
fortunately while Ebola is highly
virulent several factors limit its
contagiousness unlike viruses that
proliferate through small airborne
particles Ebola only exists in bodily
fluids such as saliva blood mucus vomit
or feces in order to spread these must
be transmitted from an infected person
into another's body through passageways
such as the eyes mouth or nose and
because the disease's severity increases
directly along with the viral load
even an infected person is unlikely to
be contagious until they have begun to
show symptoms while Ebola has been shown
to survive on surfaces for several hours
and transmission through sneezing or
coughing is theoretically possible
virtually all known cases of contraction
have been through direct contact with
the severely ill with the greatest risk
posed to medical workers and friends or
relatives of the victims this is why
despite its horrifying effects Ebola has
been far less deadly overall than more
common infections such as measles
malaria or even influenza once an
outbreak has been contained the virus
does not exist in the human population
until the next outbreak begins but while
this is undoubtedly a good thing it also
makes Ebola difficult to study
scientists believe fruit bats to be its
natural carriers but just how it is
transmitted to humans remains unknown
furthermore many of the countries where
Ebola outbreaks occur suffer from poor
infrastructure and sanitation which
enables the disease to spread and the
poverty of these regions combined with
the relatively low amount of overall
cases means there is little economic
incentive for drug companies to invest
in research though some experimental
medicines have shown promise and
governments are funding development of a
vaccine as of 2014 the only widespread
and effective solutions to an Ebola
outbreak remain isolation sanitation and
information
you